hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is the Japanese language
or you know as it's called in Japanese
Japanese has around 126 million native
speakers making it the ninth most spoken
language in the world if we focus on
native speakers alone its spoken mainly
in the Northeast Asian nation of Japan
and also to a limited extent in some
emigrant communities and amongst some
elderly people living in Japan's former
colonies like Korea and Taiwan Japanese
belongs to the japonic language family
which also includes the endangered UQ on
languages of Okinawa and the umami
Islands but the early history of
Japanese and its relationship to other
languages is largely unknown there are
theories that the Japanese and Korean
languages share a common ancestor and
there are theories that Japanese and
Korean are part of a wider language
family called the Altai ik language
family which also includes the Turkic
languages Mongolian and the tongue gusik
languages but the Altai ik language
family and the connection between
Japanese and Korean are theoretic
they're hotly debated and are not
generally accepted there are also
theories that Japanese arose from
contact between the language of the
Yayoi people who migrated from the North
East Asian mainland into Japan two to
three thousand years ago and the
language or languages of the Jomon
people who were already living there but
the nature of the language is that these
two groups of people spoke is not
clearly known Japanese was not a written
language in its early history during the
Yayoi period which leaves us very little
evidence of what it was actually like
during that time in the third century CE
II the yamato state in japan established
relations with china and the next 600
years would be a period of heavy chinese
influence during which the rulers and
the elite thought that emulates many
aspects of Chinese culture written
Chinese was probably introduced to Japan
in the 4th century and since japanese
had no written form classical chinese
became the first literary language used
by the elite later Chinese characters
began being adapted to write Japanese
the
earliest examples we have of Japanese
writing are from the 8th century and
there are two forms come boom pendant
and mañana Nanyang gonna come boon was
the writing of Japanese in classical
Chinese style using Chinese characters
to represent the meaning of Japanese
words these texts were essentially
Chinese but were intended to be readable
in Japanese man Yan Ghana was a way of
writing Japanese entirely in Chinese
characters with most of the characters
representing the phonetic sound of the
underlying Japanese syllables for
example the Japanese word for mountain
yama was written using these two Chinese
characters for their phonetic value
rather than using the Chinese character
which means Mountain which is the
character used today and not only one
Chinese character was used for each
sound numerous different characters
could be used to represent the same
sound for example the syllables cough
could be represented by any of the
following characters writing Japanese
characters phonetically using Chinese
characters that had no connection to the
meaning must have felt like a lot of
unnecessary hard work so two systems of
simplified phonetic characters developed
from the manual gaana system in the 8th
and 9th centuries in order to simplify
the writing process these two systems
were keyed Agana
and katakana one of the main uses of
these new kana systems was to annotate
[ __ ] boon text so that Japanese speakers
could read these classical Chinese or
Chinese style texts as though they were
Japanese Chinese characters represented
the meaning of the content words while
kana provided the pronunciation as well
as the grammatical elements and
inflections that were not present in
Chinese some diacritic marks also
indicated how to change the word order
when reading the text in Japanese this
method of annotating Chinese texts with
kana was the precursor to the modern day
ponies writing system through this
process of trying to make the written
Chinese language fit with the spoken
Japanese language a huge amount of
Chinese vocabulary entered Japanese
Chinese characters were sometimes
annotated to be pronounced with their
Chinese pronunciation known as own Yomi
and sometimes pronounced as a native
Japanese word with a similar meaning
these pronunciations are known as who
knew
such Chinese words have become an
integral part of Japanese comprising 60%
of the total vocabulary particularly in
writing during the late middle Japanese
period from the year 1185 to 1600
Japanese continued to develop and moved
closer towards modern Japanese
phonological II in particular towards
the end of this time period in the year
15 43 the first Europeans visited Japan
and some European vocabulary entered
Japanese through contact with traders
and missionaries this contact mostly
came to a halt during the period of
national isolation from 1603 to 1853
during this time contact with foreigners
was strictly limited to a couple of
specific places like the Dutch Trading
Post Dejima in Nagasaki a significant
number of Dutch loanwords did enter
Japanese during this time period
some of them common everyday words like
palaces from class and sit from lump
coffee from coffee coffee from coke
these words are examples of gain angle
loanwords aside from chinese borrowings
and compounds normally loanwords from
european languages which are normally
written in katakana this period of
isolation took place during the Edo
period during which the capital moved
from Kansai to Adel present-day Tokyo
and the Edo dialect became the standard
variety of Japanese after this period of
isolation ended in 1853 interaction with
the outside world greatly increased and
this affected the Japanese language as
it entered the Meiji period the number
of gaya Daigo began to increase but even
more than that many new compound words
were created from Chinese characters and
pronounced using their Chinese
pronunciation the own Yomi pronunciation
these new compounds words were created
to represent new Western concepts as
well as advanced academic vocabulary in
the arts sciences math and technology
these new words that were coined using
Chinese characters are referred to as
wasps a Kangol which means something
like Japan made Chinese words since the
end of World War two Japanese has
adopted a large number of gotta Eagle in
particular from English some of these
represent everyday modern concepts like
Conchita
and others represent specialized
vocabulary of academia and technology
during the Meiji period such specialized
vocabulary would have probably been
created from Chinese compounds but in
recent decades English has been a much
bigger source of new vocabularies
varieties of Japanese standard Japanese
today is based on the dialect of Tokyo
but there are also numerous unique and
colorful regional and local dialects as
well there are the distinctive dialects
of the Kansai region which other
Japanese people often associate with
comedy then there are the dialects of
Tohoku which a lot of people have
trouble understanding and there are the
dialects of Okinawa which retains some
elements of the area's albrecht yuan
languages and many more almost
everywhere you go in Japan there is a
distinctive local dialect the dialects
of today are much closer to standard
Japanese than they were in the past
there are still some people who speak
full-on traditional dialects in
particular older people working-class
people and people in the countryside
basically if someone meets at least two
of those criteria that person probably
uses much more dialectal speech than a
lot of other people the majority of
people speak something close to standard
Japanese but with some elements from the
traditional dialect and when speaking
politely to strangers or in formal
situations people tend to avoid
dialectal speech so what is Japanese
like phonology the basics of Japanese
phonology are quite simple
there are only five vowels in Japanese
ah there are also long versions of these
vowels ah
[Music]
the distinction between short and long
vowels is important to the meaning of
words Japanese vowels are always fully
articulated and are not reduced like
they sometimes are in English the
consonants of Japanese are for the most
part similar to those of English and
cause few problems for learners Japanese
syllables basically all end in a vowel
this makes pronunciation fairly simple
because there are a few consonant
clusters you normally don't have to
pronounce multiple consonants side by
side there are a couple of exceptions to
this one is doubled consonants for
example the word atfal if we pronounce
these characters separately they are
and coal but because the consonants in
these two syllables is the same they
merge together as one lengthened
consonant written with a small letter to
between them to indicate that you hold
the consonant for twice as long you
don't say coal but coal another
exception is having a nasal sound
followed by another consonant the nasal
sound mmm functions as its own syllable
without a vowel so we have words like
can't I which means Cheers
to be completely precise each Japanese
kana character represents a rhythmic
unit called a mora rather than a
syllable so in the word kanpai there are
four distinct mora
but if we think of it in terms of
syllables it has just two syllables and
in this word at ball there are four
Moroz but in terms of syllables
it just has two so there are a couple of
situations when a syllable doesn't end
in a vowel but for the most part
syllables end in vowels this becomes
very clear when you look at some of the
guide aegyo foreign loan words in
Japanese in English there's cake but in
Japanese it's cakey with the vowel e at
the end and notice the long vowel is
much more distinct in Japanese another
example in English hard disk in Japanese
how does it get and here's a bit of a
wild example how do you say McDonald's
in Japanese now put on an adult this
aspect of Japanese phonology may make it
a little bewildered to use loan words
from English or other languages but it
makes it easier to pronounce native
Japanese words one aspect of Japanese
phonology that can be challenging for
learners is pitch accent this is
something that a lot of learning
materials don't even mention at all
japanese Moroz have either a high pitch
or a low pitch with the high pitch
representing the accent of a word there
are cases when pitch accent indicates a
distinction and meaning for example C
meaning end this word has an accent on
the second Mura okay this word has an
accent on the first Mora and hay meaning
chopsticks and this word has an accent
on the second amaura
pitch accent also differs depending on
the dialect of the speaker for learners
incorrect pitch accent rarely creates
problems for communication but it does
give you a distinct foreign accent word
order the basic word order of Japanese
is sov subject-object-verb with the verb
coming at the end in English we have
Paul ate takoyaki or Paul ate some
takoyaki but let's keep it simple for
now
in Japanese this sentence is Tokyo me
top takoyaki by the way are fried
octopus dumplings here's the subject
followed by the subject markers yeah
then the object followed by the object
marker oh and here's the verb but in
Japanese various elements of the
sentence can be dropped if they are
obvious from the context if you're
speaking about yourself and you say tap
on Kyoto Delta with no subjects this is
understood as meaning I ate takoyaki but
if you're speaking about your brother
then it would be understood as he ate
takoyaki or if somebody asks who ate the
takoyaki the answer might be like I say
got Omata meaning I ate it even though
the object is not mentioned again the
object is obvious from the context or
let's say you ask Mickey where does the
takoyaki go takoyaki on token econo
you'll probably say panna cotta meaning
I ate it even though there's no subject
or object they're obvious from the
context there are also equation all
sentences that contain no verb but they
end in a verbal form a verbal form can
be a noun plus a copula or an adjective
plus a copula if you don't sound like
you ensure that this means Ichiro is a
baseball player here there's no verb
just the subject plus topic marker which
will come back to you later then an elm
plus the copula dot can associate a
lockpick IDUs this means this sushi shop
is expensive here we have the subject
topic marker then an adjective plus a
copula death notice that the copulas are
different dot is the casual form while
deaths is the polite form if we want to
say the second sentence casually we take
away the copula since da is not used
after adjectives only nouns
topic marker and subject marker just now
we saw two special little words flaw and
gah what is the topic marker and goth is
the subject marker what's the difference
they both seem to be placed after the
subject of the sentence right well the
topic marker wha is used when you want
to talk about something that is already
part of the conversation and make it the
topic so that everything else in the
sentence relates to it take this example
tanaka-san my association today this
means mr. Tanaka is a nice person the
use of wah in the sentence means that
mr. Tanaka has already been mentioned in
the conversation with something like the
nuance of speaking of mr. Tanaka he is a
nice person the subject marker got on
the other hand is used when you
introduce something new to the
conversation Killa sensei taught that
this means the teacher got angry today
here sensei
the teacher is new information this is
the first time the teacher has been
mentioned in the conversation by the way
in the sentence you could add one after
joke to make kill the topic of the
sentence gah also has a second important
use which is to focus on something for
example if you say what does the goggle
how could it that means I'll cook a meal
with emphasis on I in English we do this
by stressing and increasing the volume
of a word like I'll cook a meal to be
honest I prefer to think of God as a
focus marker because of the use I just
mentioned and also because it can be
used to mark the object when the object
is stressed doughnuts are gotta be tight
which means I want to eat donuts with
the emphasis on donuts or you could
think of it like donuts are what I want
to eat God is also used to mark the
object of certain state of verbs for
example canaima a was educated in this
sentence a goal is the object and the
subject is cutting and it's also the
topic in which case walk is used instead
of God there are also some other
sentences in which what seems to be the
object is actually the subject and is
marked by a gun for example being Gogol
[ __ ] which means I want an apple
word-for-word it's Apple subject marker
or focus marker want in the sentence
Hoshi
is actually an adjective meaning
desirable so the subject is Dingle
but learners would often mistake bingo
for the object and try to use the object
martyr Oh Japanese has numerous other
particles aside from wah and AH
particles are words that indicate the
relationship of a word or a phrase or a
clause to the rest of the sentence they
always come after the word they're
connected to some show grammatical
function of the word like wah gah and
the object marker Oh while others
function like prepositions
for example Kedah meaning from nee
meaning to and no meaning of or showing
possession a good nation japanese is to
a large extent and a looot native
language particularly in its verbs in
agglutinative languages words have a
relatively high number of morphemes
rather than expressing an additional
idea by adding an extra word you can add
an additional affix to an existing word
let's say this simple verb afford it
which means to get angry or code is the
stem and to is the dictionary form ND
which we can take away we can add
various suffixes to the stem to add to
its core meaning 0.98 it this is the
passive form of get angry and it can be
translated as to be scolded let's get
rid of the lute and add top wear on it
that this means I got scolded or someone
got angry at me and note that this is
just a verb with no pronouns but who
you're talking about would be clear from
the context top indicates the past tense
now let's go back to the stem and add a
different suffix acidity which creates
the causative form but when I said it
meaning to make someone angry now let's
take this do away and add this when I
say tight this means I want to make
someone angry just from this word we
don't know who someone is
but the object would be clear from the
context even though the meaning is weird
let's say this means I want to make you
angry now let's make this a negative to
do that we take off e and replace it
with coo to make a connecting form then
we add 90 point I think a good night
this means I don't want to make you
angry
and again the you part depends on the
context now let's make it past tense
o cholestatic una
this means I didn't want to make you
angry
Nakata is the past tense form of night
with top indicating the past tense so
you can see that Japanese verbs are
highly aleut native vocabulary and the
writing system as I mentioned before
when talking about the history of
Japanese Japanese vocabulary is a
combination of native Japanese words for
libel Chinese loan words or words
created from Chinese characters tumble
and loan words from other languages or
dying off a typical Japanese sentence
includes kanji or Chinese characters as
well as he began one of the two kana
syllabaries that I mentioned earlier the
Chinese characters sometimes represent
Kongo so the kanji are pronounced with
their own Yomi but they sometimes
represent native Japanese words
pronounced with their kunio me some
native Japanese words are also written
in hiragana but he Tigana
is mainly used for writing the
grammatical elements of the sentence
such as particles and inflections but
that's not gonna get up good night this
means I don't want to go to school today
word for word is AI topic marker today
school ii don't want to go here let's
start with the verb its dictionary form
is if you akito-kun ie means don't want
to go the Chinese character here
represents the meaning go
but phonetically it only represents the
first syllable e and ki comes after the
kanji that's because this sound changes
depending on the form of the verb the
way that suffixes are added to the stem
is meant to be read in hiragana this use
of heeda Ghana to show the inflections
and part of a kanji pronunciation is
called Okuda Ghana moving back a little
we have that goal this is a Congo a
Chinese compound it's followed by the
particle knee meaning to then here we
have kill another Congo then we have
watashi which is a native Japanese word
represented by a Chinese character using
it kun Yomi pronunciation let me pause
for a little side note here I've been
saying Oh Naomi and kunio me as though
there's just one a reach for every kanji
but it's not really that simple there
are often multiple own Yomi readings and
multi
[ __ ] Yomi readings for a single
character and some of them have
additional irregular pronunciations when
used in names which pronunciation you
use depends on the context for example
when you see a coup d Ghana you know
that you're using a coup Naomi and not
an onion and a quick side note about
Congo many Congo can be turned into
verbs by adding the word pseudo meaning
to do for example yo D which means
cuisine and you already see it which
means to make food or to cook kill it up
it means cooperation and kill looks it
it means to cooperate some japanese
sentences also contain katakana usually
to represent guide ie go foreign loan
words that aren't Congo
Camila no sky categorical night this
means I don't know how to use the camera
word-for-word its camera possessive
particle use way subject markers don't
know here we see the word comida written
in katakana then we see the kanji
meaning use followed by Okuda Ghana II
so we know it's a Cunha my pronunciation
then there's kata which means way so sky
kata means way of using then we see the
subject marker or focus marker in this
case marking the object then we see waka
donna e which means I don't know again
this is a Chinese character with Okuda
Ghana there are no Congo in this
sentence the two syllabaries hiragana
and katakana are more or less two
versions of the same script each letter
in either alphabet has an equivalent in
the other and they often look fairly
similar except that katakana tends to be
more angular while hiragana is rounder
why do some hit Agana and katakana pairs
look so similar while others don't
well if you remember from before the
kana syllabaries developed from kanji in
some cases kita ghana and katakana
characters developed from the same
country but in other cases they
developed from different kanji
the Kama syllabaries are quite easy to
learn but as learners of Japanese
inevitably discovered reading a sentence
written entirely in kama is actually
harder than reading a sentence that
contains kanji provided that you know
the kanji
that's because kanji give you an
immediate visual cue of a word so you
understand the meaning more quickly than
if you have to phonetically pronounce
all the kana
as you can see Japanese is a fascinating
multifaceted language in fact there are
so many different interesting aspects to
the language that people feel
intimidated because they think that they
can't learn everything well who cares if
you learn everything you don't need to
know 2,000 kanji characters or be really
good with honorifics in order to talk
and make friends with Japanese speakers
or to enjoy Japanese manga animation and
music Japanese is a very rewarding
language to learn even at a basic or
intermediate level and the richness of
the language will provide you with
countless treasures to discover no
matter how far you go with the language
special thanks to Hitomi who recorded
the Japanese samples for this video
she's not only a Lang focused viewer she
is also a special woman in my life
my partner in crime and a lovely person
please say hi to Hiromi in the comments
down below be sure to follow Lange focus
on Facebook Twitter and Instagram and
once again I want to say thank you to my
amazing patreon supporters especially
these people right here on the screen
for their monthly pledges an exclusive
bonus seen on Japanese honorific
language will be available to these
people and some other patrons on the
Lange focus patreon page bonus Clips
like this are one way of saying thanks
to my patrons thank you for watching and
have a nice day
[Music]
[Music]